In our story,...
...we find Maverick pushing the envelope of human performance and aviation.
Control, this is Darkstar, how do you read?
Darkstar, control, loud and clear.
Working in partnership with Lockheed Martin and Skunk Works,...
...we were able to create Darkstar, our full-scale prototype for the film.
One last ride.
We based the design on the fastest aircraft,...
...the SR-71, which Lockheed built in the 1960s.
The team wanted to go beyond that.
We integrated their Skunk Works designers with our designers on the film side.
We lowered it a little bit.
It also made it look a little bit sleeker and faster.
The cockpit was mind-blowing,...
...like the intel of where everything would be for a pilot.
You really wanted to believe that it was real.
Through their design team,...
...we learned how to make the plane look angry, mean, insanely fast.
It felt like something that could truly fly.
The partnership with Lockheed Martin was invaluable.
There's no way we could have done Darkstar the way we did without their help.
We wanted that moment in the Darkstar flight.
Come on.
We just feel not only the command to fly, but the beauty of flight.
He's the fastest man alive.